This is the Chris Abraham show.
To a brand new deep dive.
Glad to be here.
I want you to start by just
pictured a scenario for me, OK?
And I really want you to put
yourself in this headspace.
Have you ever spent years
building something?
Oh yeah.
Right.
Maybe it's a a a massive multi
phase work project or a complex
creative endeavor.
A novel you've been drafting for
a decade.
Exactly.
Or even just building a tight
knit team culture at a startup.
You've poured hours, weeks,
months into this thing.
The foundation is set.
The end game is insight.
Yes, the end game is insight.
And then, have you ever watched
it all burned down in a single
impulsive moment of glorious,
irreversible, terrible
stupidity?
A painful.
Thought it really is, but if you
have, you are going to deeply,
uncomfortably relate to the
absolute train wreck we are
unpacking today.
It is quite the train wreck.
We are looking at a pair of
highly unusual, intimately
connected source documents.
Very unique sources today.
Yeah, the first is a raw, uncut
2 1/2 hour audio transcript of
the final fateful session of a
tabletop role-playing campaign.
And we're talking about a group
of friends who have been running
the notoriously brutal Cursive
Strad module.
Right, for somewhere between 18
and 24 months.
A massive time investment.
Huge and the second source is a
personal post mortem audio
reflection recorded by one of
the players, Chris Abraham, who
played a character named
Bradley.
It's an incredibly revealing
pair of documents, honestly.
Because we rarely get both
sides.
Exactly.
We rarely get the unedited real
time audio of a group's
catastrophic failure right
alongside the solitary
psychological aftermath from the
person who essentially pulled
the pin on the grenade.
Pulled the pin is putting it
mildly.
It really transcends the context
of just a role-playing game it
does.
It serves as a profound case
study in human impulsivity, the
fragility of collaborative
storytelling under immense
pressure, and really the
intricate, unforgiving design of
consequence based systems.
So you aren't just going to
recount the tactical errors made
in the mark halls of Castle
Ravenloft?
No, we are going to isolate the
exact mechanical and
psychological breaking points.
The exact moments that caused a
seasoned group of players to
completely abandoned rational
decision making.
That is the mission for today's
Deep Dive.
Deconstructing the anatomy of a
spectacular failure.
We're going to look at how
someone willingly throws away 2
years of investment in a single
suicidal charge.
And then, once the dust settles
on that terrible decision, we'll
pull back the curtain on the
massive, hidden world of secrets
they left behind.
The alternate timelines, the
agonizing what ifs.
The things they never even knew
were there.
Let's jump right into the thick
of it, because the transcript
doesn't ease you in at all.
No, it drops you right in.
Right in Meteor Res, you're
immediately dropped into a
chaotic, terrifying combat
encounter deep inside Castle
Ravenloft.
And the party is locked in a
desperate fight with an entity
that the Dungeon Master Sean
refuses to name conventionally.
He just refers to it as the
hate.
Which is brilliant.
It really is.
The nomenclature alone is a
master class in psychological
warfare by the Dungeon Master.
Well, he doesn't call it a demon
or an elemental or a stalk.
Calling it the hate strips away
the player's ability to
categorize it.
It makes it abstract.
It elevates the threat from a
mere stat block to a lethal
concept, and mechanically, Sean
leverages the environment and
the rigid rules of the system to
induce a very real sense of
claustrophobia.
And panic.
You can hear it.
The audio at this point is just
dripping with anxiety.
The primary mechanical terror
here is that the entity is
completely invisible.
Right.
Imagine trying to swat a deadly
Hornet, but you're blindfolded.
Exactly.
They are trapped in this
enclosed space and because they
can't see the target, they are
swinging wildly at disadvantage.
Meaning they rolled 2 dice, take
the lower number and just
constantly miss it.
Drastically throttles their
action economy and their morale.
Every single attack is a
desperate, flailing guess.
And the compounding pressure is
what makes this encounter so
devastating.
The invisible nature of the
creature is bad enough, but Sean
stacks the deck further by
enforcing the creatures
communities with chilling
impartiality.
Yeah, let's talk about Yuri Horn
for a second.
Ah.
Yuri.
Listen to the transcript.
When Yuri attempts to lock the
battlefield down, he casts in
Snaring Strike.
Hoping to wrap the creature in
magical vines.
Just to at least reveal its
position or restrict its
movement.
The spell triggers, but Sean
calmly informs the table that
the creature cannot be grappled.
It cannot be paralyzed, made
prone, or restrained.
The players are throwing their
best control tactics at a
literal brick wall.
And offensively, the hate isn't
using mundane slashing or
piercing damage.
No, it's dealing massive amounts
of force and Thunder damage.
It's physically blasting them
with concussive shock waves,
rattling the characters and the
players alike.
At one point, Shawn describes
the hate, treating the
characters like literal rag
dolls.
It's terrifying.
There's this incredibly
cinematic, horrific moment where
the entity grabs Yuri Horn and
hurls him straight out of a
castle window.
Out onto the Parapex, into the
freezing Barovian rain.
He is literally defenestrated.
They even pause the game to
morbidly joke about the word
defenestration.
Which is a great word, but the
tactical reality of that moment
is absolute devastation.
The party's physical formation
is shattered.
They are no longer a cohesive
unit focusing fire.
They are isolated individuals
getting systematically picked
off.
If we abstract this out, it
perfectly simulates how tightly
integrated teams breakdown in
high stress business or survival
scenarios.
Unit cohesion is the first
casualty of overwhelming
pressure.
Once communication lines are
scrambled and physical or
operational proximity is
severed, panic just fills the
void.
The players stop coordinating
their abilities to synergize
with one another.
They regress to a state of pure
reactive self preservation.
And that fragmentation leads
directly to the cascade of
failures that follows.
Which brings us to Pearlin.
Poor brave Pearlin.
Poor Pearlin.
He's a halfling monk, vastly
outsized by everything in this
castle, but he is giving it his
all.
He's burning through his key
points using Flurry of Blows.
Joking nervously that he's just
going to try and pop it in the
knee.
But the disadvantaged mechanic
is just too punishing.
He's burning his resources and
missing continuously.
And then the hate pivots its
attention back to him.
The audio captures this awful
moment of realization.
The monster unleashes its
attacks and Perlin takes 22
points of force damage in a
single concussive blow.
He drops TO0HP immediately.
The shift in the room's energy
is palpable in the recording.
This is where the cold,
indifferent math of the system
asserts itself over the
narrative the players want to
tell.
Dropping to zero hit points
forces the game into a
completely different tempo.
The tactical skirmish pauses and
the raw mechanics of survival
take over.
Perlin is dying.
Forced to make death saving
throws on the freezing stone of
the parapet.
And he rolls a critical failure.
A natural one on the die. 2
failed saves instantly.
He bleeds out right there on the
stone.
He is permanently, irrevocably
dead.
The visceral gut punch in the
audio is haunting.
The players just stunned into
silence for a moment before
quietly muttering.
This character did not last
long, I'll tell you that much.
It's a brutal, sudden end to a
character they've journeyed
with.
Think about the times you've
been part of a long term project
or a complex organizational
rollout where a critical load
bearing pillar suddenly
unrecoverably fails without
warning.
That sudden absence doesn't just
damage the project.
No, it fundamentally alters the
psychological state of every
surviving member.
For Radley and Yuri Horn
Perlin's sudden death flips a
heavy switch in their brains.
They transition instantly from a
mindset of we are heroes
engaging in tactical combat to
we are prey and we need to run.
The objective is no longer
victory, the objective is merely
surviving the next 6.
Seconds.
That survival instinct kicks in
hard.
Radley, played by Chris Abraham,
the voice of our post mortem
source, realizes the math is
against them.
He openly admits he's trying to
wipe the green cowardice off his
hands.
He disengages from the hate
fully, abandoning Perlins corpse
and bolts.
He manages to scrape Yuri Horn
off the ground, reviving him
from unconsciousness, and the
two of them just run.
They have no plan, no map, just
a desperate need to put distance
between themselves and that
room.
Their desperation completely
overrides their situational
awareness.
The transcript details them
finding a dark staircase and
just descending.
And Sean's description here is
vital.
He emphasizes that the stairs go
down, down, down into the pitch
black.
They're descending past the
recognizable architecture of the
upper floors and plunging
blindly into the subterranean
levels of Ravenloft.
They are letting their fear
dictate their navigation.
Sean is quietly, almost
sadistically, noting that this
staircase doesn't even connect
to the main thoroughfares of the
castle.
They are running entirely off
the board into the deepest
Darkest Dungeon infrastructure.
They finally hit a door at the
bottom, and this is where we
witnessed the absolute
deterioration of logical
gameplay.
What does a veteran player do
when they are hanging on to life
by a thread deeply entrenched in
a vampire lore's cursed
stronghold and they encounter an
unmarked door in the pitch
black?
Well, Radley decides to kick the
door open like an action movie
SWAT team.
He kicks it so hard it flies
open, smashes against the
interior wall and rebounds,
slamming shut again.
It's a comical image, but the
recklessness of it is
staggering.
It perfectly illustrates A
psychological concept incredibly
familiar in competitive gaming
and professional poker.
Tilt.
Yes, tilt.
Tilt is a state of mental or
emotional confusion, frustration
or exhaustion where a person
abandons their optimal
calculated strategy and adopts a
highly aggressive, emotionally
driven approach.
The players are profoundly
tilted.
They are drained.
They just watched a comrade die
horribly and their cognitive
load is maxed out.
They're making decisions based
on adrenaline rather than
analysis.
Total unadulterated tilt.
So they compose themselves, open
the door properly this time.
And the environment Sean
describes?
It should have been a massive
red flashing light.
Oh, absolutely.
It's a 30 foot square room with
a 20 foot vaulted ceiling.
Standing in deep alcoves facing
each other in perfect symmetry
are two 9 foot tall iron statues
of Knights on horseback with
their swords drawn.
Suspended from the ceiling by
thick, heavy iron chains is a
massive wooden framed hourglass
the size of a dwarf.
And dead center in the room is a
fiercely burning stone Brazier
filled with white flames that
bizarrely emit no heat at all.
The environmental storytelling
here is screaming at them.
Everything about the
architecture of this room is the
textbook definition of a lethal
trap.
When you place oversized
statues, unearthly flames, and
suspended mechanisms in a
symmetrical room deep in a
dungeon, you are telegraphing to
the players that they need to
proceed with extreme caution and
high perception.
Right on the edge of the Brazier
are 7 spherical colored stones,
red, orange, yellow, green,
blue, indigo and Violet.
And etched in glowing common
script on the base of the
massive hourglass is a poem.
It is explicitly a puzzle room.
It's a Riddle hinting at a
teleportation network.
It's their way out.
The optimal play here is so
obvious.
Take a short rest, bandage your
wounds, read the poem carefully,
and decode the exit strategy.
But tilt has completely consumed
them.
The impulsive trigger that fires
next is almost hard to believe.
Yuri Horn, who is operating on
absolute fumes and pure,
unfiltered frustration, looks at
this intricate, ominous setup,
turns to Sean and declares.
I expletive.
Judy chop the hourglass.
He chooses to make a mundane
unarmed strike against a massive
suspended magical object in a
room guarded by giant iron
statues.
A Judy Chop.
The sheer absurdity of trying to
karate chop a dwarven sized
hourglass in a cursed castle.
And the system's response is
instantaneous and merciless.
Sean calmly dictates the
consequences.
The 29 foot iron statues animate
their heavy metal hooves,
striking the stone as they step
off their pedestals.
Simultaneously, the room floods
with a toxic, blinding green gas
and searing flames.
Sean asks for ADC 18
Constitution saving throw.
It's a brutal check of their
physical endurance against a
high level trap.
Unsurprisingly, they both fail.
The Mathematic of this failure
are staggering and they
perfectly illustrate the danger
of taking blind aggressive
action in a collect system when
you are emotionally compromised.
The trap unleashes 55 points of
poison damage and 22 points of
fire damage.
Yuri Horn's innate resistance to
poison halves that specific
damage type, but it is entirely
irrelevant.
Both players are already
severely depleted from the
invisible stalker upstairs.
This massive, sudden influx of
area of effect damage overwhelms
the remaining hit points
instantly.
They both dropped to 0.
They are bleeding out on the
floor of a toxic room surrounded
by animated Iron Knights.
It is a catastrophe authored
entirely by their own
impatience.
Both Radley and Yuri are now
rolling death saving throws on
the cold floor. 3 successes to
stabilize, 3 failures and you're
erased.
Radley rolls his first save.
Failure.
The tension in the audio is
suffocating.
He rolls his second save.
He is 1 bad roll away from
following Pearl and into the
grave.
He picks up the 20 sided die for
the third time, rolls it, and it
lands on a natural 20.
Mechanically, a natural 20 on a
death save is the rarest
cinematic miracle the system
affords.
It defies the fading odds.
You don't just stabilize and
remain comatose, you instantly
regain consciousness with
exactly one hit point.
You snap awake, gasping for air,
lingering on the absolute
razor's edge of mortality.
It's a second chance, handed
down by the dice gods
themselves.
It's a phenomenal moment,
Bradley gasps awake.
The trap seems to have run its
course.
Or reset.
The statues are dormant.
The gas is cleared.
Yuri Horn is still bleeding out
beside him.
Radley quickly uses a medicine
check to bind Yuri's wounds and
stabilize him.
So put yourself in Radley's
boots for a second.
You are miles beneath A hostile
castle.
You have exactly one hit point.
If you trip over a loose
cobblestone, you die.
Your only ally is unconscious on
the floor.
You are standing next to a
magical teleportation brazer.
What is your next move?
The only rational move is risk
mitigation.
You hunker down.
You take a short rest to expand
hit dice and regain some health.
Or you meticulously decipher the
poem to figure out which colored
stone teleports you to a safe
zone, perhaps outside the castle
entirely.
So you can regroup, mourn
Pearland, and strategize.
But Chris Abraham's postgame
recording provides A fascinating
psychological autopsy of what
actually happens next.
He labels his own cognitive
process in this moment a perfect
storm of stupid.
That's putting it mildly.
Radley walks over to the glowing
poem.
Sean reads it aloud for him.
Cast a stone into the fire.
Violet leads to the mountain
Spire, orange to the castle's
peak, green to where the coffins
hide, indigo to the Master's
bride, blue to ancient magic's
womb, yellow to the Master's
tomb.
The master Stride von Zarevich,
the vampire Lord, the apex
predator of the campaign.
The hubris of what follows is
staggering to analyze.
Chris is fully aware of his
character sheet.
He knows he has one hit point
out of a maximum of 46.
He knows his ally is unconscious
and cannot assist him.
He knows that teleporting
directly into the final boss's
layer in this condition is
tactical suicide.
Yet the allure of the epic
narrative, the intoxicating idea
of a heroic climax, completely
overrides his logical faculties.
In his audio reflection, Chris
notes that the player behind
Yuri Horn was hyping him up,
saying wouldn't it be epic,
dude, if you could just go in
there and with one hit point,
kill the big baddie?
The desire to author a legendary
moment actively sabotages the
pragmatic goal of survival.
Chris's self-awareness in the
post mortem is wild.
He literally says I know that
there's nothing more heroic and
stupid than with one hit point
at a 36I double down.
Sean, as a good Dungeon Master,
actually tries to offer him a
lifeline.
He pauses the game and
explicitly asks, Are you certain
ending the campaign now is what
you want to do?
He is begging Radley to read the
room.
But Radley is locked in.
He says yes.
He picks up the Yellowstone,
tosses it into the Brazier,
watches the flames shift to a
brilliant yellow, and leaps in.
When you listen to Chris
deconstruct this later, he asks
himself, was I hangry?
I mean what was the reason?
He eventually admits it was a
profoundly selfish decision.
By choosing to go out in a blaze
of glory, he unilaterally
destroyed 18 to 24 months of
future collaborative gameplay
for the rest of the table.
In the specific structure of
Curse of Stride, if even one
player survives and escapes, the
narrative thread continues.
By committing his character to
inevitable death, he severed
that thread for everyone.
It's a brilliant demonstration
of how our innate craving for a
satisfying, dramatic conclusion
can cause us to blatantly ignore
the unglamorous, necessary
mechanics required to actually
achieve success.
The teleportation sequence spits
him out into the confrontation,
the environment Shawn describes
as dripping with gothic dread.
The heavy scent of freshly
turned earth.
A massive vaulted ceiling 30
feet overhead.
Dead center in the dark silent
tune sits a shining black coffin
of finely waxed wood adorned
with brilliant brass fittings.
Readily approaches, throws back
the lid, and there he is, Strad
von Zarevich, the ancient
vampire Lord, lying there with
his eyes closed, seemingly
comatose.
It is the quintessential set up
for a classic horror movie
climax.
The monster is vulnerable in his
sanctuary.
The Batter hero stands over him,
weapon drawn, ready to strike
the final blow.
And Radley just unleashes
everything he has left.
He starts stabbing Stroud wildly
with his mundane sword.
He narrates that he's trying to
decapitate the vampire because
Stroud is technically
unconscious.
Radley is rolling with
advantage.
He's hitting every time.
He's rolling maximum damage on
the dice.
He is pouring every ounce of his
characters remaining will into
this assault.
And this is exactly where Sean
brings down the cold, unyielding
hammer of the game's mechanics.
Dungeons and Dragons is at its
core a rule based simulation.
You cannot permanently dispatch
an ancient, magically warded
vampire Lord with a standard
piece of sharpened steel.
Sean clinically explains the
reality of the situation.
Radley did not possess a wooden
stake to paralyze the vampire.
He did not possess a magical
weapon capable of bypassing
Strode's supernatural.
He had no holy symbols, no
radiant magic, and no sunlight.
Mechanically speaking, Radley's
desperate maximum damage attacks
are functionally equivalent to
hitting a brick wall with a
feather.
Sean's delivery is wonderfully
impartial.
He absorbs all of Rally's damage
rolls, looks at his notes and
says even with maximum damage,
Stroud isn't even bloodied.
Stroud's eyes simply snap open.
He looks down at his chest,
inspects his ruined, though
bloodless shirt with mild
annoyance, and lets out a
mocking laugh.
He looks up at this battered,
desperate adventure and purrs
Radley, the last of our heroes.
It is the ultimate brutal
subversion of the hero's
Journey.
The climactic sacrificial charge
doesn't end with a triumphant
world saving blow.
It ends with a dismissive
chuckle from an apex predator
who is barely inconvenienced.
Strad doesn't even draw a
weapon.
He simply reaches up from his
coffin, sinks his fangs into
Radley, and effortlessly drains
that single, solitary henpoint.
Radley.
He falls dead.
It is a definitive total party
kill by TPK.
The campaign is extinguished.
Yuri Horn is still lying
unconscious back in the trap
room, destined to be devoured by
wandering ghouls.
Everyone is dead or doomed, and
traditionally this is where the
story ends.
The heroes failed.
Close the book, roll the
credits.
But the audio recording doesn't
stop.
This brings us to the most
fascinating part of the
transcript.
The game is over, but the deep
dive is just beginning as we
pull back the curtain on the
lore dump.
The tonal shift in the room is
immediate because the campaign
has officially concluded the
players are no longer bound by
the restrictive rules of in game
discovery.
Sean is no longer the
adversarial keeper of secrets.
He becomes a tour guide through
the Museum of their failures.
For the next hour of the
recording, Sean lays all his
cards face up on the table,
revealing the staggering amount
of content, lore and vital items
the players completely missed.
I want you to imagine struggling
with a convoluted piece of
enterprise software for over a
year.
You've built these insane,
complex workarounds.
You've pulled your hair out in
frustration.
And then the day you finally
quit, an IT specialist leans
over your shoulder and says, oh,
didn't you know you just had to
click this one toggle in the
settings menu?
That absolute agony of the
hidden.
An easy button is exactly what
this next hour feels like for
Chris and the table.
Let's look at the arsenal of
magical items they unknowingly
walk past.
The most glaring omission is the
Sun Sword.
This is a legendary artifact
within the module, essentially
functioning as a fantasy
lightsaber.
It emits true sunlight and deals
massive radiant damage, which is
the specific kryptonite for
vampires.
But the location of the Sun
Sword is the cruelest irony of
the entire 2 year campaign.
Sean reveals that the Sun Sword
was hidden and inside the tomb
of Sergey Stroud's murdered
brother.
And Sergey's tomb was located in
the exact same crypt room where
Radley had just committed
suicide.
If Radley had ignored Stroud's
coffin, walked 10 feet to his
left and opened Sergey's tomb,
he would have found the 1 weapon
capable of turning the tide.
Hearing the players groan at
that revelation is painful, but
Sean keeps twisting the knife.
He brings up the Amulet of
Ravenkind.
This is an item specifically
designed to allow the party to
cast literal blindness ending
daylight.
And Sean breaks down exactly why
missing this item doomed them
from the start.
Let's say Radley did have a
magical sword and somehow
managed to reduce Straw to zero
hit points.
In the mechanics of Borovia,
Stride wasn't die at 0HP.
He transforms into an
invulnerable mist, floats back
to his coffin, regenerates his
health, and begins hunting the
party again.
The absolute only way to prevent
that mistransformation and
secure a permanent kill is if
Stroud is bathed in sunlight
when he drops to 0.
Without the Amulet of Ravenkind
or the Sun Sword, victory was
mathematically impossible.
Stroud would have just poofed
into mist and laughed at them.
Then Sean reveals the icon of
Ravenloft, a 12 inch silver
statuette that acts as a
localized battery of divine
protection.
It casts protection from evil.
It provides healing.
It bolster saving throws.
It is a massive, indispensable
boon for surviving the castle's
horrors.
However, Sean explains the
brilliant, wicked alignment trap
the designers built into it.
If any character who is not
inherently of good alignment
attempts to touch the icon, it
blasts them with 60 points of
radiant damage.
Sean.
Reminds the table that earlier
in the campaign, another player
tried to grab it and was nearly
vaporized.
But the true tragedy The Hafling
monk Purlin.
The character who rolled a
critical failure and died on the
parapets right at the start of
this final session.
He was the only party member
with a good alignment.
He was the only person in the
entire group who could have
safely attuned to and wielded
the icon.
It's like a meticulously plotted
Greek tragedy.
The one character capable of
holding the ultimate defensive
shield is killed off right
before the final push.
But the mechanical failures are
only half the story.
Sean then starts unpacking the
narrative tragedies they left
unresolved, starting with the
lore of Tatiana and Irina.
This is the dark romantic core
of the entire module.
Sean explains that Irena and NPC
the party had been escorting
much earlier in their adventure
was actually the reincarnation
of Tatiana.
Tatiana was a woman from
centuries past who was the
object of Strad's obsessive
toxic love.
Strad literally murdered his own
brother, Sir Guy to claim her,
prompting Tatiana to throw
herself from the heights of
Castle Ravenloft to escape him.
The curse of the land ensures
she is reincarnated over and
over, and Strad eternally hunts
her down.
Sean reveals the mist salvation
for this cycle of abuse.
He explains that the module
provides a very specific escape
route for Irena's soul.
If the party had successfully
escorted her to a specific
gazebo overlooking a blessed
pond in a town called Kresk, a
divine event would have
triggered.
A column of holy light would
have descended, the spirit of
Sergey would have materialized
from the water, taken Irena's
hand, and her soul would have
finally escaped the cursed Demi
plain of Borovia forever.
Permanently denying Strad his
eternal prize because the party
failed to follow through on her
escort mission, Irena was left
vulnerable, eventually captured
and doomed to repeat the cycle.
As if that wasn't depressing
enough, Sean shares this
hilarious yet incredibly bleak
anecdote about another group of
players he ran this exact module
for.
This alternate group actually
managed to get Irena to the
gazebo in Kresk.
The holy light shines down.
Sergei's spirit emerges from the
pond.
The music swells.
And the players operating on
weapons grade paranoia
cultivated by Monts in Barovia
immediately assume it's an evil
illusion conjured by Stride.
We tackle Irina to the ground,
drag her kicking and screaming
away from her literal eternal
salvation, and lock her inside
an insane asylum for her own
protection.
They permanently ruined her
soul's chance at heaven because
they thought they were
outsmarting the Dungeon Master.
Shawn noted that Irena never
spoke to them again.
That anecdote perfectly
encapsulates how deep seated
player paranoia can completely
short circuit the intended
narrative arcs built by the
game's designers.
The players become so
conditioned to expect betray
betrayal that they attacked
their own redemption.
And Speaking of hidden truths,
Sean was on to the concealed
identities within the world.
The party had spent considerable
time interacting with a
flamboyant, eccentric half elf
Bard named Rick Tavio.
Sean casually drops the bomb
fell that Rick Tavio was a
magical disguise worn by the
legendary vampire hunter Rudolf
Enrichten.
And then Richten's back story is
arguably the darkest piece of
lore in the entire setting.
Shawn explains that decades ago,
a faction of Vistani kidnapped
Van Richte's young son Erasmus
and sold him to a vampire.
Van Richten spent years hunting
them down only to discover he
was too late.
His son have been turned into a
vampire spawn.
Van Richten was forced to stake
and kill his own undead child.
The agonizing trauma of this
event, combined with the dying
curse of a Vistani seer he
killed in retaliation resulted
in a literal magical curse upon
Van Richten.
Anyone whoever allies with him,
befriends him, or weights
alongside him is doomed to die a
horrible death.
The psychological weight of that
curse dictates Van Richten's
entire existence in Barovia.
He operates in total isolation.
Sean explains that van Richten
even deliberately abandoned his
brilliant, capable protege, a
woman named Esmerelda Davenir,
solely to protect her from the
lethal radius of his own cursive
proximity.
The players had actually seen
Esmeralda's brightly painted
Vardo wagon parked ominously
outside an abandoned tower
earlier in the campaign.
The players hear this and
immediately say, oh man, we
should have explored that wagon.
We probably missed so much loot.
And Sean just starts laughing.
He reveals the lethal reality of
Esmeralda's paranoia.
She and Van Richten do not take
chances.
The door to that vardo wagon was
heavily magically trapped.
If any player had attempted to
open that door without the
precise bypass mechanism, it
would have instantly detonated
100 bottles of alchemist fire
stored inside.
Sean does the math for them
right there.
It would have unleashed 80
points of fire damage in a
massive radius, instantaneously
vaporizing the entire party
before they even knew what hit
them, just for turning a
doorknob.
Which serves as a brilliant
Segway into the broader cosmic
irony of the campaign setting.
The entire architectural
philosophy of Borovia is
designed to be a meat grinder,
yet it is intricately layered
with brilliant narrative
subversions.
Let's examine the revenants that
Arjun Vostholt.
The players encountered this
ruined mansion filled with an
ancient order of undead nights.
From a standard RPG perspective,
the logic is simple.
These undead nights hate Stride.
Therefore, they must be powerful
allies we can recruit to help us
kill Stride.
But the truth, Sean reveals, is
incredibly twisted.
The revenants explicitly do not
want Strad to be destroyed.
Their leader, Vladimir
Horngaard, understands the true
nature of Borovia.
He knows that Strad's existence
as a vampire in this realm is
not a reign of terror, It is a
prison sentence.
Strad is trapped here, endlessly
tortured by the reincarnations
of Tatiana.
The revenants hatred for Strad
is so absolute, so pure, that
they want to keep him alive just
so he is forced to suffer his
eternal curse.
Sean explains that if the
players had somehow recruited
them, those Knights would have
actively turned against the
party to prevent them from
striking the killing blow.
And yet there was a hidden path
to redeem the order.
Sean mentions the skull of the
ancient silver dragon Argenvost.
The players had actually been
inside the bone ossuary of
Castle Ravenloft earlier, a
massive room constructed
entirely of bones.
If they had possessed the
insight to locate the Dragon's
skull within that room and
simply returned it to the
Dragon's Mausoleum, back of the
Night Stronghold, it would have
ignited a magical silver beacon.
This beacon would have put the
tormented souls of the Revenants
to rest and provided a massive
permanent defensive aura to the
players for the remainder of the
campaign.
They walked right past the
trigger for their own salvation.
It is agonizing to listen to
them realize how close they were
to these massive turning points.
But Sean saves the ultimate
twist, the deepest structural
secret of the campaign's
architecture, for last.
Let's play out the hypothetical.
Let's say Radley didn't roll a
natural 20.
Or let's say he did have a sun
sword in the amulet.
He rallied the party and they
actually managed to kill Stride.
They win, right?
They save the land.
Wrong.
Sean introduces them to the
concept of the Dark Powers.
These are unknowable Elder Evil
entities trapped in a
subterranean complex called the
Amber Temple.
They are the true architects of
this reality.
They're the ones who created the
misty borders of Borovia,
sealing it off from the
multiverse.
They're the ones keeping straw
trapped as their personal
tormented plaything.
The foundational system of the
setting dictates that even if
the player successfully executes
Strad, burn his body to ash and
salt the earth, the victory is
an illusion.
The Dark Powers will simply
inevitably resurrect him.
He is the designated Dark Lord
of that specific realm.
A prison requires a warden.
The cycle is eternal and
unbreakable within the strict
Canon of the module.
There is no permanent victory
over Strovanzarevich.
But here is where Sean flexes
his brilliance.
As a Dungeon Master, he had
planned a custom, incredibly
dark twists specifically
tailored for his friends.
He tells them if you had
actually managed to kill Strad,
I wasn't just going to let the
Dark powers hit the reset
button.
Because Irena Tatiana's
reincarnation was still alive in
their specific game at that
moment, Sean was going to have
her ascend.
He.
Planned to rule that the trauma
of her endless cycle combined
with the sudden power vacuum of
Strad's death would cause Irena
to embrace the darkness of the
Amber Temple.
She would become the the new
Dark Lord of Borovia, replacing
her eternal tormentor.
And in her first fleeting act of
lingering humanity, before the
corruption fully took hold, she
would mercifully open the misty
borders just long enough to
allow the players to escape.
It is a breathtaking piece of
narrative design by the Dungeon
Master, but it poses a massive,
unsettling philosophical
realization for the players at
the table.
They spent two years fighting a
fundamentally rigged
game-winning didn't mean healing
the world or defeating the
ultimate evil.
It merely meant resetting the
trap for someone else or
swapping out the prisoner in the
cell.
Their entire struggle was cosmic
theater.
Which perfectly transitions us
into the aftermath and the meta
gaming.
How exactly does a group of
friends process losing 2 years
of imaginary, emotionally taxing
work?
Well, if you listen to the final
minutes of the audio, the tone
is surprisingly, profoundly
wholesome.
Despite the crushing absolute
defeat, the players are
laughing.
There is no resentment toward
Sean.
In fact, they express immense
gratitude.
They recognize the sheer
logistical and creative effort
it takes to run a multi layered
jigsaw puzzle of a world like
Barovia, constantly tracking all
these moving parts, factions and
butterfly effects.
There's a fascinating, very real
world detail mentioned during
this wrap up banter.
Sean the Dungeon Master was
dealing with a real world
federal government furlough at
the time.
He wasn't receiving his paycheck
at his actual job navigating
real world financial stress, yet
he was still pouring hours of
his free time every week into
prepping this intricate,
depressing world for his friends
to escape into.
It beautifully highlights the
deep social contract, the mutual
care, and the profound
appreciation that forms the core
of tabletop role-playing.
But Chris Abraham, the architect
of the suicidal charge, handles
his lingering guilt in a very
fascinating, very 21st century
way.
He takes this entire massive
audio transcript of their
failure and he feeds it into
various AI tools.
He specifically mentions using
notebook LM to have various and
sundry AI agents evaluate his
behavior.
He is literally risking an
algorithm.
Was his final one HP charge
tragic?
Was it a heroic sacrifice?
Or was it just undeniably
stupid, irresponsible and
desperate?
It is a totally modern, almost
dystopian way of seeking
absolution for a fictional
mistake.
Chris knows his friends forgive
him, he mentioned.
They just laughed bemusedly to
his face about it, but he
clearly feels the internal
weight of throwing away the
campaign.
He turns to the cold,
analytical, emotionless
judgement of a machine learning
model to tell him if the
narrative weight of his heroic
heroic intention somehow out
balances the mathematical
stupidity of his action.
It's a fascinating attempt to
extract objective meaning from a
chaotic, highly emotional
failure.
And clearly this group has not
learned their lesson about
punishing masochistic game
systems, because before the
recording cuts out, they are
already excitedly discussing
what they're going to play next.
Sean pitches a new system to
them, a grim dark Renaissance
era RPG called Spyhander.
He gleefully explains to the
table that unlike D&D, where
your characters eventually
become demigods, in Swyhander
you are just a miserable,
fragile person.
Characters routinely start the
game with hideous diseases,
missing limbs or crippling debt.
The mortality rate makes Borovia
look like a vacation.
If you get into a minor Tavern
brawl, you spend 2 weeks in a
hospital bed risking infection.
They are absolute, undeniable
gluttons for punishment.
It speaks to the resilience of
the human spirit, or perhaps
just the sheer addictive joy of
collaborative suffering.
They are more than ready to dive
back into an even more
unforgiving, brutal system,
armed with the harsh lessons and
the psychological scars of their
spectacular failure in Castle
Ravenloft.
They didn't beat the game, but
the game gave them a memory they
will dissect for years.
What an incredible journey to
unpack.
We started with a deep dive into
a game that ended not with a
triumphant, swelling orchestral
victory, but with a foolishly
brave, doomed 1HP charge into a
fundamentally rigged system.
And in failing so completely, so
spectacularly, they left behind
a beautiful, tragic web of
unseen stories, missed
artifacts, and doomed romances
that we get to appreciate from
the outside.
I think the core take away here,
whether you were we're running a
tabletop game, designing a high
stakes business strategy, or
just navigating the complexities
of life, is that taking the
impulsive heroic shortcut almost
always requires you to
completely ignore the necessary
unglamorous mechanics of
success.
Hubris blinds us to the tools we
need and the realities of the
systems we're operating within.
But on the flip side, it is very
often the spectacular,
catastrophic failures that yield
the most fascinating, enduring
stories.
Nobody talks for two years about
the project that went perfectly
according to plan.
We analyze the wreckage.
We absolutely do.
So I want to leave you, our
listener, with a final
provocative thought to Mull over
building on that terrifying
concept of the Dark Powers
holding Stred hostage.
A rigged system.
Exactly.
If we discover that a system we
are operating in is
fundamentally inherently rigged
against us, much like the Dark
Powers, ensuring that the
villain will eternally return no
matter how hard the heroes
fight, does a suicidal, futile
act of rebellion actually lose
its meaning because it
physically achieves nothing?
That is the question.
Or in the universe that is
meticulously designed to break
you down, rob you of agency, and
trap you in a cycle?
Is choosing the exact moment in
the spectacular manner of your
own defeat, the ultimate, purest
expression of free will?
It is a heavy, lingering thought
when structural victory is truly
impossible.
How you choose to lose becomes
your defining act of defiance.
Thank you so much for joining us
on this deep dive into the
crypts of Ravenloft.
We've loved unpacking the
anatomy of his failure with you.
Stay curious.
Keep exploring the hidden
mechanics of your own world.
Today we're examining a really
fascinating piece of source
material.
We are looking at the detailed
transcript and the post game
breakdown of the final session
of a very long running tabletop
role-playing campaign.
And not just any campaign,
right?
This was set in the famously
unforgiving gothic horror world
of Curse of Strad.
Exactly.
The central disagreement we are
exploring today revolves around
the final, fateful action taken
by player Chris Abraham.
He was controlling the character
Radley Fulhorn, who was
sometimes affectionately known
at the table as Deadly Deadhorn.
And, well, what an action it
was.
Right.
So, after miraculously surviving
a devastating trap with exactly
one hit point remaining, Radley
intentionally uses a magical
teleportation Brazier to cast
himself directly into the
vampire Lord Strad's tomb.
He initiates A suicidal attack
on the sleeping antagonist,
which swiftly results in a total
party kill and abruptly ends the
entire campaign.
Now I will be arguing that
Radley's final charge, while
perhaps mechanically doomed from
the start, was a narratively
satisfying and remarkably heroic
conclusion to a very desperate
situation in a grim, dark
setting.
And I'll be taking the opposing
view here.
Radley's choice was a tragic,
selfish strategic failure.
By throwing his character into
an obviously unwinnable
encounter, he unnecessarily
destroyed 18 to 24 months of
future gameplay.
And you know, he denied the
entire table the opportunity to
uncover the campaign's
incredibly rich hidden lore.
To really understand the weight
of that final choice, I mean we
have to look closely at the
narrative reality of that exact
moment.
Radley's decision was, in my
view, the only narratively
honest choice left for a broken
survivor.
Honest.
Yes, honest.
Just look at the trauma this
party had endured in the hours
prior.
They were decimated by an
invisible, ungraphable entity
known only as The Hate, which
relentlessly battered them with
massive force and Thunder
damage.
Well, it was a.
Brutal encounter, certainly.
Beyond brutal.
This creature literally threw
another player character, Yuri
Horn, out of a window and
permanently killed their
halfling monk Purlin.
The sheer desperation is
palpable.
In the transcript.
Radley and Yuri managed to
escape down 87 dark stairs,
completely isolated from the
rest of the castle, only to
stumble into a trap room.
Yuri Impulsively, Judy chops an
hourglass, triggering an
absolutely devastating trap that
fills the room with toxic gas
and fire.
We're talking 55 poison and 22
fire damage.
Both characters immediately
dropped to 0 hit points.
Which usually means death in
this system.
Right, they are bleeding out.
When you hit zero, you roll what
players call death saving
throws, literally rolling a 20
sided die to see if your
character perishes or hangs on.
Against all odds, Radley rolls a
perfect natural 20.
A very lucky roll.
Very lucky and that mechanic
dictates he instantly wakes up,
but with just a single fragile
hit point.
He manages to stabilize Yuri so
he won't bleed out, but the
situation is utterly dire.
This created a cinematic nothing
left to lose scenario.
Diving into the yellow
teleportation fire wasn't some
cold mechanical calculation.
It was a bold, heroic blaze of
glory moment when you were
standing in the dark with a
single breath of life left
striking at the heart of the
darkness is the essence of a
hero's journey.
Look, I can appreciate the
romance of a tragic final stand,
but you're ignoring the reality
of the medium here.
This isn't a scripted novel,
it's a collaborative game.
Tabletop role-playing is
fundamentally about resource
management and group
storytelling.
Radley's decision was driven by
an impulsive desire for personal
glory that entirely disregarded
the mechanics of the game and
the social contract at the
table.
How was it disregarding the
social contract to play your
character authentically?
Because you have to look at the
concrete alternatives available
to him.
He had just successfully
stabilized the unconscious Yuri.
The Dungeon Master.
Sean Scanlon explicitly
confirmed in the post game
breakdown that the trap room
they were in was completely safe
to take a long rest in once the
gas had cleared.
But let me finish.
For those unfamiliar, a long
rest is essentially an 8 hour
sleep that allows characters to
heal their wounds and reset
their abilities.
They could have recovered.
You keep bringing up this idea
of a safe room, but we have to
look at what safe actually means
to a character in that specific
moment.
You are applying hindsight.
The Dungeon Master confirmed it
was safe after the game ended,
but we are analyzing a
role-playing game where
decisions must be made based on
character knowledge in the
volatile present.
Even without hindsight, the
Brazier puzzle provided crystal
clear escape routes.
The glowing poem in the room
explicitly offered survival.
It promised that the green
magical stone led to a coffin
maker shop in a nearby town, and
the Violet stone led to a
mountain Spire.
Half of the stones in that
puzzle would have safely
evacuated them from Castle
Ravenloft.
Sure, but.
By deliberately choosing the
Yellowstone, which was
explicitly labeled yellow, to
the master's tomb while
possessing only one hit point
and a standard non magical
sword, Radley made a
mathematically hopeless choice.
Mathematically hopeless perhaps,
but psychologically sound,
Radley is standing in a 30 foot
square room.
There is a fiercely burning
stone brigier and two animated 9
foot tall iron statues of
Knights on horseback that had
just nearly incinerated him.
From the character's
perspective, there is absolutely
no logical reason to believe
that sitting down to roll out a
sleeping bag for 8 hours in that
room is a survivable plan.
Right, but.
The invisible entity that killed
their monk could theoretically
track them.
The iron statues could
reanimate.
Sitting still probably felt like
a guaranteed death sentence.
But charging the vampire Lord
with a single hit point isn't a
death sentence.
Come on.
It is, but it's a death on his
own terms, and we can't forget
the collaborative aspect you
mentioned earlier.
Yuri Horn, the only other
surviving party member, actively
enabled and encouraged this
suicide mission.
When Radley is contemplating the
Yellowstone, Yuri urges him on.
He literally says go do it, kill
him.
This wasn't a single rogue
player ruining the game for
everyone else.
It was a.
Collaborative embrace of a
heroic death by the last two
broken survivors of a doomed
expedition.
Right, but enabling a bad
tactical choice doesn't make it
a good narrative. 1 Intellectual
charity requires acknowledging
the text, and I cannot accept
that this was just pure
unadulterated character agency
acting logically.
The text itself undermines that
defense.
How so?
The player, Chris Abraham,
explicitly admitted his own
culpability in the post game
recording.
He calls his action a perfect
storm of stupid and outright
labels it a selfish, heroic
decision.
A player being self deprecating
after a dramatic failure is
pretty common in tabletop
gaming.
It doesn't invalidate the
narrative weight of the choice.
It's not just self deprecation,
it's an acknowledgement of the
game's mechanics.
He acknowledged that his
character's constitution was
weak, that he had exactly one
out of a maximum 46 hit points,
and that he threw away what
might have been another
enjoyable year or two of
gameplay for the entire group.
Even the Dungeon Master gave him
the classic Are you sure you
want to do this?
Which is terrifying.
Exactly, that is a universal
signal in tabletop gaming that
you are about to make a
catastrophic error.
The DM offered him an
opportunity to back down and
Radley double down.
I would argue that backing down
in that moment would have felt
entirely hollow.
Hollow or not, Dungeons and
Dragons operates on a framework
of rules.
Charging the final boss of a
massive campaign without any
magical amulets, without proper
healing magic, and, crucially,
without wooden stakes to
actually paralyze a vampire is a
fundamental failure of the core
mechanic that makes the game
function.
The narrative only works when it
interacts meaningfully with the
mechanics.
I hear you, but.
This wasn't a calculated risk,
it was an abdication of the
game's premise.
You can't solve a complex lock
by hitting it with a hammer,
which is essentially what Radley
did to the campaigns final boss.
You're touching on something
crucial there, but I think you
are focusing entirely too much
on the mechanical futility of
the action.
Yes, hitting the lock with the
hammer doesn't work, but I would
argue that this futility was
based on missing information
that the character could not
possibly have known.
You are retroactively applying
the Dungeon Masters postgame
Lord dump to judge a character's
in game decision.
But the Lord Dump proves
precisely why the action was so
destructive to the experience.
It highlights exactly how much
of the game they chose to
bypass.
Let's examine what we actually
learned from that postgame
breakdown.
Radley teleported into the tomb,
found Stroud asleep, and landed
a maximum damage attack.
Eight points of slashing damage
plus 12 points of strength.
A massive blow for a standard
weapon.
And yet Stroud wasn't even
bloodied.
It was completely ineffective.
Why?
Because the party had missed
every single artifact required
to actually win the campaign,
they miss the tone that held the
crucial lore about the vampires
weaknesses.
They miss the legendary Sun
blade, which was hidden just
across the crypts and is
necessary to create daylight.
Most importantly, they miss the
specific amulet needed to cast
that sunlight and stop Straud's
regeneration.
Wish again they didn't know they
needed.
But the mechanics of the world
dictate that without sunlight,
even if Radley had miraculously
reduced Strad to zero hit
points, the vampire would simply
turn to mist and regenerate in
and his coffin.
Add to that the fact that the
party's halfling monk who died
earlier was the only character
with a good moral alignment,
right?
Perlin.
Yes, Perlin.
That meant he was the only one
who could even touch the
powerful holy icon in the castle
without taking 60 points of
damage.
The entire mechanical framework
of the campaign dictates that
you must gather these specific
tools to defeat the antagonist.
Ignoring that framework isn't
bravery, it's ignoring the
puzzle the Dungeon Master spent
months building for you.
I reject that framing because it
penalizes the player for the
gaps in the character's
knowledge.
Radley didn't know that his
sword wouldn't severely wound
the vampire.
He didn't know that Strad would
regenerate infinitely without
that specific amulet precisely
because they missed the lore
book that would have explained
it.
You have to look at this from a
tactical in world perspective.
From a tactical perspective,
attacking a vampire Lord alone
with one hit point is absurd.
Is it?
Imagine you are a desperate
fighter.
You find yourself standing over
the shining black coffin of your
seemingly invincible enemy, and
he is fast asleep.
That is the ultimate tactical
advantage.
Why would a fighter take that
shot?
If a player calculates that this
is the best, most vulnerable
state they will ever catch the
villain in, punishing them for
taking a brave risk based on
their limited information
severely undermines the spirit
of immersive role-playing.
It's not punishing them, it's
applying the rules of the world
they're playing in.
But the game isn't just a
spreadsheet of optimal moves and
required inventory items.
It's a living narrative where
characters act on what they
perceive.
Radley saw an open coffin and a
sleeping monster.
He took his shot.
That is pure, unadulterated
character agency.
If we demand players only act
when they have mathematically
solved the campaign, we strip
the danger and spontaneity out
of the storytelling.
Spontaneity is one thing, but
burning down the theater is
another.
Have you considered the sheer
volume of world building and
narrative potential that was
sacrificed for that single
moment of unadulterated agency?
The Dungeon Master crafted an
incredibly intricate world,
balancing multiple factions and
complex character arcs.
Radley's choice essentially
burned the final chapters of a
masterful book before anyone
could read them.
I think Burned is a bit
dramatic.
The story simply ended
differently than expected.
It ended prematurely, leaving
massive emotional storylines
permanently unresolved.
Think about what the table lost.
There was the storyline of the
doomed reincarnation Irena, a
woman the party was supposed to
escort to a specific sacred
gazebo in Kresge, where a divine
light would allow Sergey's
trapped spirit to rescue her and
let her escape this cursed realm
forever.
That beautiful redemptive arc?
Gone.
A tragedy, yes, but fitting for
the setting.
But they never got to experience
the tragedy.
Then we have Rudolf Van Richten,
the legendary vampire hunter, a
man cursed because he was forced
to kill his own son, who had
been turned into a monster.
His curse meant anyone who
allied with him would die.
The players never explored his
trapped vardo wagon loaded with
alchemist fire.
They never resolved his pain.
Right.
And what about the entire
faction of Undead Nights, the
revenants of Argenversed Hull to
actively wanted Straw to live
forever in torment?
If the party had just returned
the skull of a dead dragon from
the castle's bone ossuary to a
specific tomb, it would have lit
a beacon, providing a massive
boon to the group.
Which sounds like another
mechanical fetch quest.
It's not just about missing
optimized items or buffs, it's
about denying the table the
resolution of deep emotional
storylines.
The Dungeon Master managed all
of this brilliantly, weaving
these threads together even
while dealing with real world
stresses like a government
furlough.
Radley's choice robbed everyone,
including himself, of the
catharsis of seeing those
threads resolve.
I hear the weight of those lost
storylines, and I understand the
frustration of leaving stones
unturned.
But we must thoughtfully
challenge the idea that this
campaign was marching toward a
traditional catharsis or a happy
ending that Ratley somehow
squandered.
You're assuming that completing
those quests would have led to a
satisfying victory.
It would have led to a complete
story at the very least.
But let's look at the revelation
regarding the dark powers that
actually control this realm at
the Amber Temple.
The hidden lore the DM shared
post game the Dungeon Master
explicitly revealed that even if
the party had done everything
right, the victory would have
been an illusion.
If they had gathered the magical
sun sword, found the amulet of
Ravenkind, and killed the
vampire perfectly in the
sunlight, these dark entities
would simply bring him back.
They keep him trapped in eternal
torment as a plaything.
That cyclical nightmare is a
staple of the gothic horror
genre.
It doesn't mean the players
shouldn't get to fight the
battle.
But it gets darker.
The DM had planned a devastating
twist.
If they somehow managed to
permanently kill Strad, the
woman they were trying to save,
Irina, the reincarnation we just
discussed, would have tragically
ascended to become the new Dark
Lord of Barovia.
She would have to take the
vampire's place just to
mercifully allow the player
characters to leave.
Which is a phenomenal narrative
twist.
Exactly, but my point is that
there was no true permanent
victory to be had.
The house always wins in the
setting.
Therefore Radleys feudal bloody
stand perfectly encapsulates the
gothic horror, an inevitable
tragedy of the source material.
Think about the imagery of that
final moment.
Radley strikes with all his
might.
The Empire is unbothered.
He wakes up, casually inspects
his bloodless wounds, laughs at
the last of our heroes, and
effortlessly drains Radley's
final hit point.
It is certainly a vivid image.
It is a perfect image.
It wasn't a disruption of the
narrative, it was the ultimate
realization of it.
Radley's death merely made the
subtext of the campaign textual.
The heroes were never going to
win.
They were always going to be
broken by this place.
Radley just forced the issue.
Thematic resonance is great, but
the medium of a tabletop game
demands a respect for the
journey over a premature player
forced conclusion.
Yes, the dark entities ensure
that the realm is a cyclical
nightmare.
Yes, the ally ascending to
become the new villain would
have been a bitter, compelling
pill to swallow.
But the crucial distinction is
that the players didn't get to
experience that realization.
They experienced a different
realization of the same theme.
They experienced a shortcut.
They didn't get to confront the
moral weight of their ally
taking the throne.
They didn't get to uncover the
tragedy of the cursed hunter by
short circuiting the campaign
with an attack that the game's
math simply wouldn't support.
Radley substituted a rich, multi
layered tragedy crafted over
months with a brief, impulsive
one.
It reduced a complex tapestry of
gothic storytelling into a
single, somewhat comical image
of a severely wounded fighter
poking an invulnerable vampire
with a standard sword.
It sacrificed deep, unresolved
world building for a fleeting
moment of glory that didn't even
mechanically register as a
threat.
We have explored some deeply
compelling arguments today,
pulling at the very seams of
what makes tabletop role-playing
such a unique medium.
To summarize my position, I view
Radley Fulhorn's final act not
as a failure of mechanics, but
as a beautifully tragic role
play driven climax.
It honored the grim reality of a
broken party trapped in an
unforgiving castle.
After losing friends to an
invisible horror and surviving A
lethal gas trap by the narrowest
possible margin, Radley made a
choice that was narratively
authentic to a traumatized
survivor.
He faced the darkness head on,
delivering A conclusion that
perfectly mirrored the
inevitable tragedy woven into
the fabric of the Perovian
setting.
And from my perspective, I
maintain that Radley's decision
represents an impulsive
rejection of strategic
alternatives and collaborative
gameplay.
In a medium defined by group
resource management and the
uncovering of a deeply plotted
narrative, choosing a
mathematically impossible
confrontation over exploring
clear avenues of escape was a
disservice to the table.
It sacrificed an incredibly
intricate, deeply crafted world
full of unresolved character
arcs and hidden lore for a
selfish and ultimately feudal
gesture that prematurely ended a
years long collaborative
endeavor.
Despite our very different
lenses on this outcome, I think
there is a strong point of
convergence between us.
We both recognize the incredible
depth of the jigsaw puzzle that
was placed before these players.
The Dungeon Master Sean Scanlon
crafted A remarkably reactive
world and managed it with
brilliant dedication.
Without question, the sheer
effort required to weave
together the fates of multiple
factions, cursed NPCS, and
hidden lore, especially while
navigating real world challenges
like a government furlough, is
worthy of immense respect.
Our debate today truly
highlights the profound
emotional investment inherent in
tabletop role-playing.
The fact that a single impulsive
choice regarding a yellow
teleportation stone can spark
such deep discussion speaks
volumes about the power of this
kind of interactive
storytelling.
It absolutely does.
Tabletop role-playing is a
unique tightrope walk.
It balances the rigid math of
mechanical strategy with the
boundless freedom of dramatic
storytelling.
Moments like Radley's final
charge sit right on the razor's
edge of that balance, for the
rules of the game in the
impulses of the character
violently collide.
We highly suggest that listeners
explore the transcripts
themselves to see how they would
have handled the puzzle of the
glowing poem, the colored
stones, and the sleeping vampire
Lord.
In this mistrouded realm of
Gothic horror, the lying between
heroism and foolishness is often
indistinguishable.
And perhaps that is exactly as
it should be.
Thank you for joining us.
Narrative recap and confessional
transcript detailing a
catastrophic campaign ending
final stand against the vampire
straw.
So let's dive straight into the
feedback.
Yeah, let's get right into it.
The narrative tension leading up
to the climax relies heavily on
mechanical accidents rather than
character driven fatal flaws.
You really feel this right at
the entrance to that puzzle
room.
Oh, absolutely, especially given
the environment the author has
meticulously established up to
this point.
Right, because the atmosphere
before this moment is just, it's
incredibly heavy.
The party has just barely
survived A devastating skirmish
with an invisible entity known
as the Hate.
Yeah, we have a permanent
character death on our hands
with Pearl and failing her death
saving throws, and Yuri Horn has
basically been tossed out of a
window like a rag doll.
It is incredibly bleak.
I mean, the survivors, Radley
and Yuri, they're descending
this endless, suffocatingly dark
staircase.
Completely isolated.
Exactly.
They are completely isolated,
their resources are depleted,
and they are desperate.
But then right standing before a
puzzle involving 9 foot tall
iron statues and a burning
brassiere.
The weakness here is that the
catastrophic trap that decimates
the party is triggered by a
seemingly random comedic action.
The sudden Judy chopped to the
hourglass.
Right, which abruptly shifts the
tone and undercuts the grave
life or death stakes of
infiltrating Castle Raven loft.
It takes the reader entirely out
of the grim reality of the
setting, like you're no longer
immersed in the terrifying
depths of a cursed gothic
castle.
No, you are suddenly reminded
that you are reading about
players sitting around a table
making jokes to cut the tension.
Which is a completely natural
defense mechanism when you were
actually playing a tabletop
game.
Oh, for sure.
When a group of friends is
stressed about losing a campaign
they've played for years, they
use humor.
Yeah, but the translation from a
live role-playing experience to
a written narrative requires
filtering out that out of
character table banter.
Right.
Retaining those literal game
mechanics and jokes and prose
severely damages the immersion.
So the suggestion here is to
reframe the inciting incident of
the trap to emphasize the
psychological toll, exhaustion,
and despair of the characters.
Making the mistake feel like a
tragic consequence of their
grueling journey rather than a
slapstick error.
Exactly.
By rooting this fatal misstep in
the character's internal state,
you maintain that oppressive,
horror driven tone.
It makes the resulting
catastrophe feel completely
earned.
Yes, it becomes a deeply human
failure of endurance rather than
a mechanical gag about an
unarmed strike.
If the characters are broken, we
just need to let their actions
reflect that brokenness
organically, right?
There are a lot of ways to
tackle this, but let's look at
some concrete examples for how
the author could pull this off.
For instance, you could really
lean into describing the
suffocating darkness of that
endless staircase.
Explicitly mention their
dwindling hit points and
physical exhaustion to
contextualize why someone might
act so rashly.
Picture this instead of stating
that Yuri impulsively, Judy
chops the hourglass for a laugh.
Right.
You frame the strike as an act
of desperate frustration, a
complete emotional breakdown.
Oh, that is so much stronger.
He could be staring at the sand
that simply refuses to fall.
Yeah, his mind is just
fracturing under the weight of
Perlin's permanent death.
Exactly.
And in this fit of hysterical,
weeping rage, he shatters the
glass just to force time to move
forward.
That changes the entire
complexion of the scene.
It transforms A comedic misfire
into a moment of profound
psychological collapse.
Or, if you want to lean into the
supernatural elements of the
setting, you could describe the
dark magic of Ravenloft actively
whispering to him.
Yes, like the environment itself
could be convincing his
exhausted mind that breaking the
hourglass or having a
hallucination born of the dark
magic is the only way to escape
the room.
Right, these are just a few out
of all possible ways of solving
the problem, but making that
adjustment ensures the
subsequent release of poison gas
and fire damage feels like a
grim, inevitable punishment.
They broke under the immense
pressure of the dungeon, and the
dungeon capitalized on it.
And think about how beautifully
that sets up the final
confrontation.
If the trap is triggered by
crushing despair, then Radley
subsequent decision to throw the
Yellowstone into the fire and
teleport to the Masters tomb
with only one hit point left.
It feels like a natural
continuation of that same
despair.
Yes, it links the events
thematically.
The entire sequence transforms
from a series of unfortunate,
clunky game mechanics into a
poignant character study on how
heroes break when pushed past
their limits.
That sense of exhaustion and the
burden of choice actually bleeds
right into the second-half of
the submission during the audio
transcript confessional.
The integration of the author's
real world logistical commentary
alongside the in universe
character tragedy creates A
jarring tonal inconsistency that
dilutes the emotional impact.
Because the author has done
incredible work establishing A
somber, reflective mood here.
It is a highly intimate,
vulnerable moment of
storytelling.
We're sitting with a narrator
who is genuinely questioning the
root of their self-destructive
impulse, right?
They're wondering if they were
simply hangry and lamenting the
demise of a character they had
spent years inhabiting who was
just about to level up to an
eldritch night.
They are mourning the profound
selfish character choice that
resulted in the loss of a multi
year campaign.
Yeah, but then the weakness is
that the confessional testimony
abruptly shifts from mourning A
profound character choice to
discussing mundane recording
tools, Zoom software, and AI
transcription processes.
Which shatters the immersive
tension built by the
protagonists guilt completely.
In the very very next breath we
are suddenly reading about how
the audio was routed through
notebook LM and transcribed by
Microsoft Word.
It completely breaks the spell.
It is a sudden, clinical
insertion of the mundane into
the profound right.
It feels as though we are
reading a devastatingly
beautiful eulogy and halfway
through the speaker stops to
review the brand of microphone
they are using to deliver it.
The reader wants to stay in that
space of mourning and reflection
with Radley's player.
We want to feel the chill of the
crypt.
Yes, the bitter irony of
surviving a deadly gas trap with
a miraculous natural 20 on a
death saving throw only to
willingly throw oneself right
into the jaws of an ancient
evil.
The suggestion here is to
isolate the out of universe
mechanical and logistical
details from the emotional
confessional, using the player's
real world reflection strictly
as a concluding epilogue once
the narrative arc has landed.
You definitely do not have to
delete this meta commentary
entirely.
No, not at all.
It holds significant value for
documenting the creative process
and understanding how the
transcript was born.
However, it needs a distinct
boundary so it does not bleed
into an corrupt the emotional
climax of the peace.
Let's discuss some concrete
examples of how to restructure
this.
OK, the very first step is
stripping the lines about
Microsoft Word and Notebook LM
entirely out of the central
monologue about the suicide run.
Exactly.
Clear out the technical jargon
so the narrator can focus
entirely on the haunting visual
of standing before the yellow
teleportation fire, right?
Emphasize that they only have a
single hit point and they know
in their bones that walking
through leads to death.
Let the text linger on the quiet
earth scented crypt.
Describe the polished black
coffin with its brilliant brass
fittings.
Lean into the sheer futility of
stabbing an ancient evil with a
non magical weapon while he
mockingly laughs at the last of
our heroes.
You can even expand on the
psychological torment of the
surviving player as they process
the fallout.
Oh, definitely.
That is so deeply relatable and
tragic.
And As for the meta discussion
about audio tools, recording
software and generating AI
feedback?
Move all of that to a distinct
author's note at the very end of
the document.
Keep it completely separated
from the character's internal
monologue.
And again, these are just a few
out of all possible ways to
solve the problem and organize
the flow, but this approach
ensures the reader is allowed to
fully process the tragedy of the
narrative before being invited
behind the curtain to see how
the artifact was generated.
You have to let the emotional
dust settle first.
Right.
This structural isolation is so
crucial for the emotional
pacing, and it actually brings
up a similar issue with how the
postgame revelations are handled
at the very end.
The extensive lore dump provided
at the end of the piece
introduces fascinating alternate
realities that currently feel
disconnected from the
antagonist's actual journey.
Yeah.
We get this massive debriefing
session where the Dungeon Master
pulls back the curtain on
everything the party missed.
And the world building is
spectacular.
We learn about the Tome of Strad
detailing the villains tragic
back story right and the Amulet
of Ravenkind which could cast
the daylight needed to stop his
regeneration.
We discovered that the Sun Sword
was hidden just across the crypt
in Sergey's tomb.
Such a great detail.
We learned the heartbreaking
truth that the Bard Rick Tavio
was actually the legendary
Rudolf Van Richten, operating
under a curse that dooms his
allies.
We even find out that Esmerosa's
trapped wagon was loaded with
alchemist fire.
Yeah.
And perhaps most strikingly, we
learn about Irina's true
parentage and a potential
salvation at the pool in Kresk
versus her terrifying alternate
destiny is the new Dark Lord of
Borovia if the party had
succeeded.
It is a brilliant, intricate
puzzle box of a campaign, but
the weakness is that profound
campaign secrets are delivered
as a dry, bulleted list of post
game trivia, rendering them as
detached facts rather than
haunting what ifs that serve the
story.
From an editorial standpoint,
presenting this huge influx of
rich narrative information as a
separate appendix fundamentally
robs it of its emotional power.
It reads like a textbook summary
of a fantasy module.
The reader is given all this
incredible world building, but
because it is completely
divorced from the protagonist's
emotional state, it fails to
elicit a meaningful response.
Right.
It is simply raw data without
any dramatic application.
The tragedy of the story isn't
just that Radley died.
No, it's that he died needlessly
inches away from the exact tools
that could have saved him and
his friends.
Providing that information as a
detached bulleted list
completely misses the
opportunity to twist the knife.
The suggestion here is to weave
these missed opportunities
directly into the protagonist's
confessional reflection, to
weaponize the dramatic irony and
deepen the tragedy of the fatal
choice.
Instead of treating these
reveals as a separate, out of
character debriefing logged at
the end of the text, integrate
them into the narrator's litany
of regrets.
Make the lore active.
Make it hurt.
By filtering these campaign
secrets through the lens of a
player who has already admitted
to Profound own guilt and
sadness over their actions, you
elevate the trivia into a
powerful thematic device.
It underscores the overarching
themes of futility, hubris, and
the devastating consequences of
acting without full knowledge.
Let's look at some concrete
examples for how to integrate
this seamlessly.
OK, instead of placing them in a
disconnected list at the end,
have the narrator agonize over
these missed paths during their
reflection.
For instance, the narrator could
lament I died stabbing him with
a mundane blade, never knowing
the sun's sword lay just across
the crypt in his brother's tomb.
That is absolutely devastating.
Yeah, the proximity of salvation
compared to the reality of their
failure is heartbreaking.
They could also reflect on the
people they failed to protect.
They could say we perished
thinking Irena was doomed,
completely unaware that we could
have guided her to salvation at
the gazebo and Kresk right.
Instead, because of my rush to
glory, she is left to inherit
the mists as the new Dark Lord.
It hits so much harder when the
narrator is actively torturing
themselves with the information.
You could have the narrator
express absolute horror at
discovering that the eccentric
bar they travelled with was
actually Van Richten.
Carrying a curse that doomed
everyone who allied with him,
the narrator could wonder out
loud if their own terrible
suicidal decision at the Brazier
was influenced by that very
curse.
Even the detail about the silver
icon of Ravenloft dealing
massive damage to anyone without
a good alignment could be
utilized, right?
The narrator could reflect that
Perlin was the only pure soul
among them who could have
wielded it, and she had already
bled out on the floor above
them.
By reframing the bulleted facts
as a desperate, grief stricken
monologue of all the things that
could have been, you ensure that
the complex world building
directly serves the emotional
climax.
Exactly.
And of course, these are just a
few out of all possible ways to
solve the problem and blend the
lore into the narrative.
Someone might wonder if the
evidence supports weaving the
lore into the actual final
battle scene itself, rather than
the confessional.
Sure.
But keeping it in the
retrospective confessional feels
so much stronger because it
authentically mirrors the actual
experience of playing a tabletop
role-playing game.
Exactly.
You only realize the true
breadth of your mistakes once
the character sheets are put
away, the game is over, and the
Dungeon Master finally opens
their notes to show you what you
missed.
Weaponizing that specific
universal post game experience
as a literary device within the
confessional is a brilliant way
to capture the unique heartbreak
of this medium.
It really is.
It honors the source materials
origins while elevating it to a
truly compelling piece of prose.
To wrap up, today's critique
focused on elevating the
emotional thematic weight of
this campaign recap.
We suggested reframing the trap
triggering accident as a
character driven moment of
despair.
We also talked about separating
the technical meta commentary
from the emotional confessional
to maintain immersion, and
finally weaving the postgame
Laura Beals directly into the
narrator's regrets to amplify
the dramatic irony.
Please implement these
actionable suggestions and we
warmly invite you to submit your
revised.
Work on the Curse of Strad
campaign finale.
You know the source captures a
hilariously tragic final session
of a Dungeons and Dragons game
where a series of absolutely
terrible, impulsive choices
leads to the total wipeout of an
adventuring party.
First, let's detail this
staggering string of fatal
mistakes.
So the party was already pretty
battered from fighting an
invisible entity called The
Hate, right?
Well, a player named Yuri Horn
impulsively punches a puzzle
hourglass.
BAM, that triggers a trap room
packed with poison gas and fire,
instantly dropping the party and
leaving a player named Radley
barely alive with exactly one
hit point. 2nd, we have to talk
about Radley's suicidal last
stand.
Instead of running away, Radley
throws a Yellowstone into a
magical fire to teleport
straight into the sleeping tomb
of the main vampire villain,
Strad.
Talk about tragic comedy.
Radley stabs the sleeping
vampire repeatedly, does
absolutely zero damage, and is
effortlessly bitten and killed
the second Strad wakes up,
ending a multi year campaign
just like that.
Finally, we get the Dungeon
Masters postgame lore dump.
After the total party kill, the
Game Master revealed all the
crucial secrets the players
completely missed, like the
sunlight producing Amulet of
Ravenkind and the legendary Sun
Sword, really highlighting how
much deep lore they bypassed
with their hasty actions.
Ultimately, this catastrophic
finale is a perfect reminder
that in tabletop role-playing
games, the deadliest monster you
face is often your own terrible
decision.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.